If you're looking for an affordable bicycle
that's durable and has great shock absorption
capabilities, then a bike made of steel is
for you.
It's a bit heavier than a high end bicycle
made of aluminum or carbon fiber.
But this rugged material buys you a smoother
ride at a significantly lower price.
There's three speed steel bicycle is sturdy
and comfortable enough to ride recreationally
or daily to school or work.
A cargo rack in the rear can hold your
purse, backpack or briefcase.
The bike is made of Chromoly steel, which is
pound for pound stronger than standard steel.
To prepare the bike's tubular parts,
including the frame, a worker cut steel tube
with a horizontal bandsaw into specific
length pieces.
He then clamped certain frame pieces into a
milling machine which will cut a curve into
one or both ends, depending on the piece's
location in the final assembly.
This notch, as it's called, will let the
tube butt up against the side of an adjacent
tube when the bike's frame is assembled.
The notched edge is ragged, so the worker
smooths it out with a small belt sander.
Certain frame parts are straight.
Others bend to make the bent ones.
Another worker places the piece of tube in a
tube bender, a press that forces the tube
against a curved die.
Once all the frame parts are ready, a welder
clamps them in a fixture which correctly
positions them for assembly.
He works with a welding torch in one hand and
a rod of filler metal in the other.
The torch melts adjacent tubes at their
meeting point so that they fuse together.
The welder also melts in some filler metal
to strengthen the joint.
The bicycle frame is made up of nine major
parts.
And the welder welds them to each other in
two sections, forming the rear triangle and
the front triangle.
This is the rear one, which alone requires
nine meticulous welds.
Once each triangle is separately assembled,
he welds them together.
Another worker sprays the frame with powder
coat primer, then color.
Powder coat is an industrial grade paint
like finish, which he bakes onto the metal at
almost 400°F for 20 minutes.
When the frame comes out of the oven,
another worker presses steel caps into what's
called the head tube.
That vertical tube at the front of the
frame, which holds the handlebars on top and
the fork for the front wheel at the bottom,
bearings inside the caps.
Let the handlebars and fork turn left and
right with ease.
To put the bicycle together.
The worker suspends the frame in an assembly
stand and then inserts the bottom bracket,
which will ultimately support the bike's
drivetrain system.
The bike's fenders are made of sheet steel
that shaped with pressure applying rollers.
The rear fender attaches to the rear dropout
and defender mounts at two other locations on
the frame's rear triangle.
He screws the cargo rack to middle and rear
rack supports.
Then he inserts and bolts the rear wheel
into the rear dropout.
The wheel hub has three built in gears.
The hub and rim are made of aluminum, which
is lightweight and doesn't rust.
The wheel spokes are stainless steel.
Next, the worker installs the drivetrain
system.
Inserting the crank arms already mounted to
the chain ring onto the bottom bracket.
He tightens the bolts securely with a torque
wrench.
Workers, then insert the fork into the
bottom of the head tube and chrome plated
steel handlebars into the top mount.
The front fender and front wheel.
Then install the pedals.
Vinyl, seat chain and chain guard with the
gear shifter and front brake lever on the
handlebars. This steel bicycle is ready to
hit the road.
For some pet owners, feeding raw food to
Fido is a natural choice.
It harkens back to the common ancestor of
all dog breeds, the wolf in the wild.
Wolves eat raw meat and occasionally some
greens.
So the theory goes that dogs are genetically
predisposed to thrive on a raw meat diet.
Dogs have been domesticated for thousands of
years, but when it comes to their diet, they
can still go a little wild.
Raw canine cuisine may be a foreign concept
to some pet owners, but it's becoming more
mainstream. The makers of raw dog food often
mix fruits and vegetables with meat to
provide fiber and create a balanced meal.
The process starts with a lot of slicing and
dicing.
A food worker chops the fruits and veggies
into smaller pieces so they'll be able to go
through a grinder more easily.
He also removes the seeds from the apples in
the squash because the seeds aren't as easily
digested as the rest of the fruit and
provide no additional nutrition.
This raw pet food recipe calls for a variety
of fruits and vegetables, though in total,
they will comprise just 5% of the meal.
The rest of the raw blend will consist of
meat, bones, organs and fish.
Another food worker chops up the chicken,
which has been organically raised and has
even been approved for human consumption.
Except for the breasts.
All the parts of the chicken will be used in
the main recipe.
This includes the heart, liver, gizzards and
the bones.
Raul. Whole sardines, anchovies and mackerel
will add essential fatty acids to the Raul
Chicken blend. All the ingredients have been
prepared and are now ready for grinding.
A worker feeds the components to the grinder
in small batches, interspersing the meat,
fish and the vegetables.
This ensures even distribution as the
Grinder minces everything to a uniform
particle size.
The result is a thick emulsion of finely
ground chicken, meat, bones, vegetables,
fruits and fish.
She transfers the minced raw ingredients to a
mixer.
The revolving paddles further blend the
food.
After about five minutes in the mixer, all
the ingredients have been combined into one
homogeneous raw mass.
This chicken blend is now complete.
The worker divides it into £5 batches and
scoops it into bags.
She vacuum seals the bag.
Removing all the air inside will allow the
raw blend to stay fresh longer, refrigerated.
It should last for up to ten days.
And if frozen, it should be good for several
months.
For the furry members of the family.
Dinner is ready to be served.
To make some raw pet snacks.
A worker decals New Zealand green lipped
mussels, a species that is believed to have
fast acting anti-inflammatory properties.
After she cuts the muscles free from the
shells, she places them on racks for air
drying. She transfers the rack into a drying
tent where fans keep air circulating 24 hours
a day. As the muscles dry, they shrink.
After 72 hours in the tent, the moisture
content is substantially reduced.
Air drying has preserved the flesh of the
mussels in the raw state while preventing
damage to the nutrients and enzymes they
contain.
Now preserved.
She packs the muscles into plastic bags and
adds an iron oxide packet to absorb oxygen
and prevent spoilage.
This raw pet food is now ready to nourish
the wolf in your dog.